with just two weeks left of 2021
president biden's hope for passing his
ambitious social spending and climate
bill has faded at least for now among
the obstacles democratic senator joe
manchin of west virginia who is
reluctant to endorse the expanded child
tax credit program that is set to expire
soon democrats are now refocusing their
efforts on voting rights legislation
christina raffini has more from the
white house christina good morning
good morning dana president biden
acknowledged earlier this week that his
nearly two trillion dollar social
spending bill won't make it in time for
christmas
i i hear the frustration
but let's not deny the impact that we've
had in a late night talk show appearance
vice president kamala harris defended
the long-awaited and long delayed build
back better plan
so we're going to keep pushing and we're
in extensive talks across the aisle with
both folks in terms of republicans and
democrats but we're not going to give up
on it at all after passing the house
last month the buildback better bill
remains stuck in the senate where it
faces procedural hurdles the
parliamentarian has not been able to
look at all the pieces yet and so she
has a few weeks of work left and
pushback from west virginia senator joe
manchin who wants to rework a proposed
extension for the child tax credit i
can't think of any more important thing
to do than to reduce child poverty in
the united states on thursday the
president said in a statement he and his
team were in close contact with manchin
and will advance this work together over
the days and weeks ahead the president
requested more time to continue his
negotiations
and so we will keep working working with
him hand in hand to bring this bill over
the finish line meanwhile the white
house is renewing its focus on another
stalled democratic priority voting
rights
this new sinister combination of voter
suppression
election election subversion
it's un-american democratic efforts to
pass election reform measures have been
consistently blocked by republicans who
call it a federal power grab
but yesterday president biden told
students at south carolina state
university and historically black
college the battle's not over we must
pass the freedom to vote act the john
lewis voting rights act we must
we're going to keep up the fight until
we get it done
the white house says president biden is
getting regular updates from his team on
this issue and that voting rights is a
priority for the administration but dana
it's not one that's going to happen
until at least next year
all right christina thank you